the uh pro bowl happened yesterday
russell wilson actually stood down for
drew brees to let him start in the pro
bowl very nice that's the right thing to
do right it's the right thing to do um
said russell wilson drew means the world
to me i respect the game and he does it
better than anybody else so
drew brees was that the last game that
he will ever start in the nfl regular
season postseason or phony pro bowl game
he says he's going to give it a month to
make a decision i'm really waiting until
football is done he said earlier this
week according to nola.com obviously
being here at the pro bowl i'm just very
much focused on my family and this
opportunity to be around the guys
playing the game then i'll kind of lay
low for a little bit get away and then
assess i kind of have a process in mind
and i'll give it a month or so look
chris i speculated on this yesterday and
i've heard some things since then which
make me believe it's true here's what's
going on in new orleans okay yeah i want
to hear this because i'm shocked by this
comment really yeah he's either going to
play for the saints or he's going to
play for no one okay so the saints have
all the leverage now yeah okay drew's
not going to go play for anybody else we
don't have to worry about him
resurfacing in carolina sure or tampa
bay right or anywhere else right so they
they get what jim irsay wanted with
peyton manning right they get what the
packers wanted with brett favre sure
they're getting what bob kraft would
love to have with tom brady yeah play
for us play for no one right so we we
dictate the terms now right and i think
the conversation behind the scenes is
going to be
drew
we need you to play less drew
we have a bigger role in mind for taysom
hill drew
we can't pay you 25 million a year if
you're not going to be the full-time
95 98 99 of the game snaps guy it's
going to be more than cameos from taysom
hill there's gonna be a transition year
for taysom hill okay we have to work
this out where we can sign him and we
can sign you but if you're gonna come
back this is the way it's gotta be yeah
we want you back right i want to do this
right and if it doesn't work it doesn't
work but i think that over the next
month mickey loomis and sean payton are
going to be trying to sell drew brees on
this idea of not co-starters yeah but
drew brees
in a lesser role than we've ever seen
him in with more taysom hill as he get
taysom hill ready to be the guy in 2021
i think that's where this is going well
i i mean um
i'm so i'm surprised to hear that i
guess is what i'm saying i'm i am and
i'm not i guess first off i mean yes
this is a delicate situation with the
new orleans saints you know yes
drew brees is still good is he great
anymore no he's not do you want to
continue to leverage the future of the
franchise on oh one more year from drew
brees so they're in that conversation
you know they really are um i am shocked
by this whole thing i really am i'll say
this you know one
i just didn't expect him to say this i
thought for sure you're just going to
come out and go no i'm coming back and
playing i really didn't so to me this
shows there's some real thought here and
maybe i don't want to come back and play
and also consideration of what other
options may be out there i think that's
part of what he's going to do right i
guess so right that as well you know not
playing right other other other thing
right other other business ventures or
whatever it may be the other thing too
is i i even feel like with russell
wilson yesterday letting him become the
starter which is a great move by russell
very respectful that way i mean drew's a
legend as we know
it makes me think too that you know drew
said something to him during the week to
go this you know this this might be it
i'm not sure i'm going to play and
russell this was his way to go okay well
maybe this is might be it you know hey
you go out and start now i don't know if
i'd like do you think what would you pay
what would you pay drew brees that's
what i was gonna go like what now now
that still has a one-year deal he's got
over 20 million dollars in dead money
from salary issues so it's gonna have to
be a multi-year deal that right but but
for one more year
cash money in hand for the 2020 season
what would you pay him all right so and
then we're go we're gonna take we're
gonna assume that like maybe now taysom
hill's gonna play what 20 of the snaps
you want to keep tasting hill right you
want to keep tasting hill who's due to
be a restricted free agent so if you pay
drew brees too much if his cap number's
too high yeah somebody may swoop in and
make an offer to take some hill that you
can't match because you can't tie up
that much money your in your quarterback
position so you want money for taysom
hill right you want to pay maybe tasty
meal 15 million next year sure how much
do you pay drew bree i think somewhere
you know around 20 i think then you got
35 million yeah russell wilson you got
russell wilson right that's where i
think it would be around there i think
that would be fair for all sides i do
you know again i love drew brees i'm not
trying to like sit here and go oh he's
not great i know it he's one of the
greats of all time but let's take into
the reality of the situation once again
here too the pa the saints went
undefeated without drew brees in the
lineup this year they went 5-0 and
that's just i'm not saying anything
about drew brees i'm just pointing out
that the saints are good and i'm trying
to point out once again as anybody that
ever listens to me say anything it's
more than a one-man sport it's the
ultimate team sport and you got to have
that around you the saints do have
something special there so this is
bigger than drew brees
in in itself but yeah i think
realistically that's probably somewhat
fair and that's the thing we're
overlooking the guy who went 5-0 while
drew brees was injured i know because if
you keep brees right and he'll you take
teddy bridgewater off the table he's not
going to hang around for another year
what are you going to pay him no if
you're paying hill 15 bree's 20. you're
gonna pay teddy five to just hang around
for another year no i don't think so
right especially if i don't know a team
like the patriots says hey it's teddy
bridgewater yeah i mean he'll come in
he'll run our offense he'll do what we
want he'll make it work sure and he's
always been a great teammate great
locker room guy great person he had his
his coming out party taken away from him
because of that fluke knee injury in
2016. so i i think that
you could have the saints
ultimately make drew brees an offer that
they know he won't accept
yeah but they know when they go to him
and say ask
what do you think he'd accept where
that's where i do think he has leverage
here right he does have leverage from
the standpoint no he doesn't once he
says he's not playing for anybody else
he has no leverage but no but he can
always go he wants to play for he if he
says he wants to play the new orleans
fan base is gonna go we want drew brees
and then he's got leverage a little
there i think well and this is where you
get into that disconnect where it's
almost like the chiefs fans who lost
their minds over what i said versus the
chiefs fans who understand football yeah
like the saints fans who are very casual
and don't pay much attention they'll
lose their minds about drew brees
leaving the saints fans who get it will
be like hey
drew brees taysom hill we see the future
we understand we understand where the
ball's moving right not where the ball
has been right so i think some fans
would be up in arms but i don't know
that drew brees wants to look whether
it's the brady new england relationship
or the breeze new orleans relationship
there's gonna have to be some very
delicate surgery on how this all gets
crafted because there is a way that
somebody could passively aggressively
try to
turn you know if dreed if drew doesn't
like i think you're right the more i
think about this if he doesn't like the
offer he gets yeah there's a way he
could posture this where
a lot of people end up being
unjustifiably upset with exactly right i
mean all it takes is his agent to call a
beat writer down in new orleans or call
somebody else to go hey drew really
wants to play the saints are doing them
dirty and they're making lowball offers
and saying and all of a sudden that'll
get all the pressure back on to the
saints and people will back drew brees
because of the status and what he's done
for that city the legendary status he is
i mean you know coming in there saving
them you know what was that after uh
hurricane
katrina 2005 yeah everything like that i
mean he's just he's a staple of that
city i i think that at the end of the
day
the saints will hope
that
during this month yeah
he comes to the conclusion they wanted
to come to whatever it is right i'll
accept a reduced role i'll accept a
reduced contract or the right thing for
me to do is walk away and hand the baton
to teddy bridgewater and taste that i
mean that's what i just find fascinating
between brees and brady that
conversation in general what number are
they willing to take to come back to
play it does seem like for whatever
reason brady's number is higher now i
mean i don't know for whatever reason he
is tom brady he's in another
stratosphere from drew brees i don't
mean to respect drew brees that but one
guy's won six super bowls the other one
one and brady is bringing a huge
marketing muscle he is right exactly
right that's where he's in a little bit
of a different stratosphere so that to
me is where this really will get
dictated and figured out is what these
guys are asking for
uh you know
money-wise
and will it be realistic within what the
organization wants to do and build going
forward and that's to me where it's
fascinating because sean payton and bill
belichick are no-nonsense guys too and i
do think they're smart enough to realize
like they don't want to ruin their team
and the future of their team just over
one player even when that player is dear
to their hearts and they have great
respect for him i think that if there is
a separation with brees and the saints
or brady and the patriots are both yeah
every move that gets made every word
that gets written or said by the team by
the player by the agent on the record
off the record everything it will be
fascinating fodder for trying to figure
out is somebody trying to stick it to
somebody is somebody trying to win the
mob in their favor is somebody trying to
make somebody else look bad that's why i
think i said this last week with brady
and the patriots a joint statement
is the only way to do it if there's
gonna be a separation yeah right where
everybody says all the right things and
that's all they say about the same page
i'm mike tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights from nbc
sports